people say why do you talk about this
one why do you talk about gender you
know why because there is no bigger life
or and this is even bigger than a Russia
hoax there's been no bigger live
perpetrator in the American public than
the idea that men and women are
completely and fundamentally
interchangeable question of the day how
do you how mainstream do you think the
view that men can get periods to all
that also includes all of modern gender
theory yeah how mention do you think it
is on the left do you think it's a small
faction at what point when you look at
every single DNC candidate putting their
his and her and Z pronouns and their
Twitter profiles you say oh let's see if
like this is sort of broken away from
the pack and it's now in the mainstream
I guess broken into the pack ooh it's
like a reverse run of the bolt yes the
head of running in looking to get gored
by hard [ __ ] [ __ ] well boys yes
this is largely partly it's a theater of
the mind people so Dennis Prager was
recently on on Bill Maher show and he
had the audacity to point out some of
the biggest lies coming from the left
and I want you to see the reaction here
because at first I had to do a
double-take say that men can menstruate
is a lie and that is now that is what it
said
not menstruate was considered
transphobic I missed this whole story
where are you getting just google it can
been menstrual first up it is funny they
said menstruate I hate the
pronounciation yeah that is actually
correct your search on it you can say it
one of both ways I love how billowy says
this is what winded I'm ill prepared for
this question so and here's what's so
crazy a crowd animator exists for all
shows right all remedy shows it's like
okay laughs when you want to go see
Letterman exactly says laugh but with
with Bill Maher there's a crowd
animators say cheer cheer this point
agree at this point so I just looked
through the audience and goes I guess it
was kind of tongue-in-cheek right his
Audion they just like left but he makes
the same argument that you hear a lot
that's a small section of liberals yeah
I guess he's missed every major article
on transgenderism from every major
publication on the MTV HuffPo
independent Telegraph People magazine
yeah all say that men can have their
periods too and by the way these aren't
just some random op-ed people not only
do we have YouTube videos here but this
is what some of these clips are from a
international sorry no it's a pandemic
which I believe means international yes
I'm happy damn it's a pandemic
thinks tampons look at these videos
some guys have periods it's a thing it
happens it's normal there's nothing
wrong with it some people might argue
otherwise but guys you have periods to
actually if a man has a period it means
he's very sick
are you talking about coming from your
ass I mean what's he just disabled this
is part from a tampon complete and so
that leaves me with by this years of
also getting my period I okay listen
this is a yeah it's just some small
Twitter faction that's what it is when
they're running national advertiser
international pandemic spins as a
mainstream in the left and by the way no
one from the DNC can stray from these
mainstream points I want to get back to
Dennis Prager and Bill Maher here um he
actually had again the audacity to point
out that UC Berkeley
they have tampon dispensers in the men's
room which of course draws more laughter
from the crowd animator for Bill Maher
at the University of Berkeley men's room
tampons are given out check it out count
UC Berkeley men's rooms have tampon
dispenser okay also University of
Wisconsin Madison University of
Minnesota Twin Cities Brown University
they all provide menstrual products and
men's rooms okay this isn't this isn't
some isolated incident by the way since
this this episode happened last week
just so you know you would think they
maybe would lay low for a bit right cuz
this is absurd isn't mainstream since
then Parents magazine not even an
activist publication have posted this on
Instagram yesterday look mowgli saying
that men can have periods to be ashamed
at least by some Vibrams planned parent
let's go down the list your Planned
Parenthood make sure to be tied with the
Democratic Party you're an organization
the United States gives over five
hundred million dollars to annually they
say that men can get periods in their
educational literature on menstruation
minced I know also by the way plan this
is an organization's coming half asian
lawyer bill richmond a little bit
uncomfortable because he was not
involved this video because i wanted to
protect him from it but Planned
Parenthood also believes that men can
get pregnant too I know I tried it
so your dad came up positive really the
only option is they can give you if that
we can give you the forms for the
Medicaid if you want to go ahead and
continue the pregnancy I am so glad by
the way let me still piss just bleep the
name for people going woman's urine
tested positive on a pregnancy test and
they couldn't say like you're sick you
have testicular cancer the baby's coming
out and this will probably be removed it
sort of been do you monetize my treat by
the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot notifications let
you know when there's an entire new
video that goes up and of course just
check in every day we have a new video
at 8 o'clock join mug club that's what
allows us to continue this is something
else do they are cuz now you can say
well it's HuffPo it's People magazine
it's Planned Parenthood it's Parents
magazine it's all these major
publications but that hasn't necessarily
made it to the national platform really
how about we go to the DNC candidates
the House overwhelmingly passed the
Equality Act which Bible would force all
institutions in America to treat
someone's identified gender as if it
were a biological fact six of the
Democrat presidential candidates six of
them have added their gender nouns to
Twitter bill less do you think you're
saying this is just on Twitter there's a
separation between Twitter and real life
well let's go to Democratic presidential
hopeful and I say hope because he's so
hopeful holy and Castro even demanded
that trans women have access to taxpayer
funded up well he didn't say trans women
taxpayer funded abortions here how he
dead named people I don't believe only
in reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice just because a
woman need or let's also not forget sign
in the trans community a transfer
this poor doesn't mean they shouldn't
have the right to exercise that right to
choose this team is like crap I'm in
Chan's mail the Craigslist calling sheet
looking for a good time MTF FTM I don't
know the point is the Sikh subculture of
course the gross one said I know that's
judgmental I'm okay with it this is
something else for your later on Bill
Maher mentions he goes on to talk about
trans athletes and he couldn't rise to
claim that oh listen this is absurd but
that's a far cry from the idea of men
menstruating listen to it at the KC mix
what you're talking about
is yes someone who is transgendered was
a man now claims to be a woman there's a
woman out of other women in the race
because of course they have more muscle
mass this is a far cry from saying men
morester wait now you catch himself like
believes there let me explain it to you
we said jim manikan his eyes and i am
dead inside the reason that he does that
ok we just had we talked about Amy is a
robot commune robot with Jim took
yesterday who had a story and I've seen
it was punted right hmm this was a woman
who had a story on possibly the biggest
most influential I guess you know
Epstein was what you would call like a
pedophile influencer like you know
social media influencers yeah Edwin sir
they could have saved potentially dozens
or hundreds of young people from being
under the thumb of Jefferson and they
punted the story and we were talking
about that mean when you see that one of
the biggest scandals ever in American
history it tells you that people with
mainstream outlets or working within
mainstream outlets they cannot do honest
journalism they are precluded from doing
it okay so let's take that carried over
why do you think Bill Maher is going
identifies no it's because he's on the
same network as lena Dunham's girls in
the new Watchmen series yeah yeah he
would be on the unemployment line faster
than Bernie Sanders can get on a Russia
honeymoon getaway this guy is going to
be gone from the network if he doesn't
play ball let's do you think that I'm
exaggerating here Democrat Ilan Omar
when she's not you know in
between in between no night at USA
powerlifting Association because they
wouldn't let transgenders compete in the
women's division she claimed that it was
a myth that power lifters were
biological males have a direct
competitive advantage at lifting weights
so she equates the idea that a man
lifting that a man has the potential to
lift more weight with Loch Ness monster
in her mind they're effectively the same
and by the way let's be clear about this
legislatively demo how Bill Maher has
missed this and this is what I do think
it's intellectually disingenuous I never
I don't want to attribute motive but at
this point legislatively considering
that he is an educated man policy
legislatively the Democrats are way past
this legislature with the Democrats have
already signed on to a platform in an
agenda that says men can men straight to
that's why they are so tied with Planned
Parenthood that's why they put their
pronouns in their Twitter profiles
that's why Julio and Castro just said
what he said about by the way
transgenders not only having the ability
to have an abortion performed which
right away that should stop the
conversation I don't care how birthing
your hips are if you're if you're a
baseball catcher in Division one it
doesn't matter you're still not gonna
have a baby
no ok not only that but legislatively
they're way past that and they try to
sidestep the question of transgender
males to females yeah now I'm getting
confused so transgender males to feel
you know what guys and dresses
they try to side simpleness what about
transgenders in sports well I think it's
kind of like she's every limitations on
abortions and and Bernie Sanders's I
don't believe that it's my place like
what about men fracturing skulls and
female mixed martial arts and they say
well you know this is fear-mongering but
legislatively they're already passed the
idea that men can have periods too and
this isn't that I think Maher really
needs to understand they dismiss it as
though it's absurd and they miss a point
that Dennis Prager was making these are
these are mammoth lies and I do this is
an important point you know Donald Trump
we've talked about it he's a bit of a
BSA right he might exaggerate the the
attendance right at his rally right he
might go out and say this is the best
economy we've ever had you know you look
at unemployment you look at Japanese
position right you look at more black
businesses because everything that black
unemployment rate you look at the median
household income when you exclude for
super wealthy earners being five
thousand dollars for the average
middle-income
compared to $1,000 for Obama $400 for
george w bush and you go you know what
he has a point there but maybe gdp isn't
as robust as he would like it to be but
that's not an outright lot you're gonna
call those lies compared to men can leak
menstruation from where their balls used
to be right yeah I mean it's that's
blood man correct
our this this is this is one thing
honest people said why do you talk about
this why do you talk about gender you
know why because there is no bigger life
or and this is even bigger than a Russia
hoax there's been no bigger lie
perpetrate in the American public than
the idea that men and women are
completely and fundamentally
interchangeable we want to talk about
Donald Trump we want to talk about
Russia we want to talk about the media
we can talk about FC all of those things
matter they're relevant sure but to try
and act as though those are more
pressing than the huge this gargantuan
lie that men and women are the same that
we do not have inherent differences
which by the way is what makes us
stronger it's what makes the family unit
stronger when you say that men and women
are fundamentally interchangeable you
first off tug at the fabric of society
by pulling apart the family and you have
a bunch of kids who don't think they
need a mother and a father because
fundamentally two moms are the same
thing as two dads and two dads are the
same thing as a dad with a dick and a
mom was a dick I got confused during
that rant and let just say it dad with a
menstruating by the way men can't men
straight it's not it's like those
Halloween it's a it's a parlor trick
it's a parlor trick and said there's
Halloween masks that you have to have
the second coating and so you squeeze
and it looks like the mask is bleeding
and it has a pump they have a pump
they're gonna menstruation you're like
no that's a lie look he's palming the
pump my point is I love it they just act
as though for a longest time they would
say this is a small faction like people
would say I think it's legitimate for
the right to say sure there are some
people who are racist and there really
is a small faction if you look at their
voting record yes the Republicans don't
vote on mass for racism they certainly
don't support racist policies they do
the opposite of that you can argue
whereas you look at the voting records
of any of these Democratic candidates
and they consistently vote for this not
only a slippery slope they are trying to
shove people down this slippery slope so
fast
the game too much speed that they end up
throwing themselves down the slope
telling you that men can have periods
two men cannot have periods Bill Maher
knows that men cannot have periods but
Bill Maher tries to act like is an
extreme view and not mainstream in the
left it is the sole mainstream view of
the left's a matter of fact I would wait
I would go as far as to say it is the
only allowable mainstream view on the
left you think that this is hyperbolic
here okay go to a leftist rally
Elizabeth Warren you have to watch it to
your fingers okay so cringy go to a
Bernie rally go to ones with a warm
rally go to any town hall where they
allow for open questions and ask them if
they think that we've gone too far in
supporting the idea that men can men
straight too or just shut out men can't
have periods and watch yourself get
booed either the only acceptable
viewpoint in the left and I don't
believe for a second that Bill Maher
doesn't know it you let me know what you
think about menstruation it's a palpable
menstruation if you enjoyed this video
subscribe or hit the notification bill
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot and of course do join Mudd Club at a
lot of credit comm slash Mudd Club you
get like eighty percent more content a
full daily show and I will tell you this
I know you might be on the fence
none of them involve men men's true
hating so we've got that going for us